so I'm actually going to talk today
about a few sort of related projects
related in the same way that I can tell
like cohesive narrative about my
research but not completely and not
specifically the law related stuff in
part because I don't yet have students
who are interested in law at all but
maybe someday but I will say before I
get started just also in case you want
to talk to me about any of these things
at some point these are some general
types of work that I do to stuff around
online communities and governance social
norms research ethics which I'm talking
about today public perceptions of
technology ethics ethics education and
then a little bit at the end about
marginalized online communities and
fandom platforms in particular so some
ethical controversies that you probably
have heard about every time I give a
talk like this there's more I have a
couple of what I say my my Hills to die
on when it comes to ethics one is about
research ethics from public data and one
is about ethics education and then a
preview of some new research that I'm
doing that I think is particularly
exciting about marginalized communities
and computational projects so you might
be wondering what is ethics this is a
really good question and one that I'm
not going to try to answer for you today
but I can give you one wrong answer and
a wrong answer to this question is that
this is what the IRB tells you that you
can do I have a lot of feelings about
IRB is and and this question in
particularly I'm not saying that I are
bees are bad I'm just saying that our
IRB is are not the arbiters of what's
ethical and in part because a lot of the
research ethics controversies that we're
seeing lately
look a lot more like these kinds of
things so examples of using publicly
available data in research so these are
just a few examples OkCupid the AI
mentioned here is also from dating sites
YouTube videos
so I've been involved in work about
research ethics for these kinds of
things and so I am part of the sig PI
research ethics community or the
committee
I've been running workshops at various
conferences on this for a few years and
I'm part of a big project to study these
things empirically and every time I
finish one of these workshops or a panel
or whatever about research ethics we end
up with this list of open questions and
I haven't changed this slide in about
four years these questions don't tend to
ever close and I'm not going to read
them to you this is more for effect but
things around use of public data in
terms of them consent and privacy and
expectations and deleted data and all of
these kinds of things and one of the
reasons that this has been a problem is
because we have this idea that research
ethics is governed by IRB s and this is
you know can power taught and that's how
we think about research ethics or the
problem is that IRB is only care about
human subjects they're about regulation
right so the reason that they exist is
because federally funded research is
covered by US law and this is what the
law is
it covers human subjects which means
either direct intervention with humans
or collection of identifiable private
information so what does not fall into
either of these categories is for
example your photo on a publicly
available dating site or a tweet and so
what we hear a lot in terms of these
kinds of projects is that
oh the data was already public and one
of my collaborators has a Google Alert
for this phrase because it's so common
and in fact this phrase which also was
the subtitle of a paper that he
published in 2010 says Michael Zimmer
was actually the exact phrase that was
used
justify the scraping of Oliver Cupid and
release of the dataset publicly was that
the data was already public of course
still pretty easy then to take this
dataset and apply it to real people and
if any of you have ever used OkCupid you
know what kind of data is on OkCupid
because you answer lots of very very
personal questions on that site so this
is something that you know people have
been thinking about I mostly kind of
grumbling about in the hallways for a
while or sometimes complaining about
interviews of papers and so one of the
things that I thought was ok we're
researchers like why aren't we
researching this problem so one of the
things that I wanted to start with was
well how is this kind of research
actually perceived by the people who are
in the data because it's not just data
right like a tweet if not a piece of
data in the same way that like a
measurement of the weather is it's
people and so one of the first studies
that I did in this space was to find out
how Twitter users feel about tweets in
research and this was a paper that I
wrote with Nick Paris who is at
University of Kentucky um this was
through a survey of Twitter users
recruited from Mechanical Turk and I
will go ahead and address the massive
obvious bias in this study which is that
people who don't like research probably
are not going to participate in my
research study about how they feel about
research and we actually thought we did
this ok well we're gonna you know run it
and then if we do the data analysis and
everyone is like yeah also and we love
research then we're just not gonna
publish it and there's like 600 dollars
down the drain but it turns out that
that was not the case so I actually
expect that the situation is even worse
that is what is reflected in this data
and we weren't interested in answering
the question like should researchers use
tweets or not cuz I have no intention of
telling the research community that we
shouldn't be using public data
there's actually a lot of really
important research that's happening but
I'm going to get to what I think is the
way that we should be using it or
thinking about it so first finding most
people have no idea this is the thing
that can happen I actually think the
number is probably a little higher than
this because Mechanical Turk or at least
kind of familiar with research
anecdotally I talked to a lot of people
about my work and often the reaction is
why would scientists care about my
tweets so the so this is not surprise me
it turns out also that almost half
thought that this isn't allowed like oh
clearly they shouldn't be doing this and
we asked them why why do you think that
this isn't allowed like what rule do you
think is being broken here and what
answer was that it's against ethical
guidelines for researchers which we know
is you know kind of not true at least we
were considering this in terms of ir B's
a lot of people also thought that it was
a violation of Twitter's Terms of
Service whereas actually in their
privacy policy it's like hey just so you
know people like university researchers
might be using your tweets I actually I
spoke to an engineer at Twitter a couple
of years ago who used to work for a good
nip so it's basically in charge of like
data collection that often is given or
sold to researchers and I said hey you
know how do you think about like the
situation where like this is a business
model for Twitter like you're selling
this data but like most people don't
actually know that their data is being
used this way he was like oh it's right
there in the privacy policy like
everyone on Twitter definitely knows
that researchers are using their tweets
I was like oh you are so wrong and I can
give you some data about that I'm not
talking about this today but I've also
done some work looking at data scraping
provisions in terms of service which I
can tell you are like completely useless
particularly since people don't read
Terms of Service so what
it says in there about whether
researchers can use data or not doesn't
actually influence anyone's expectations
of privacy on the site but what we were
particularly interested in here was what
kinds of things influence people's
attitudes about this so for example do
you think that researchers should be
able to use your tweets without
permission and most people said no and
they had various ways of talking about
why or how a lot of people wanted to be
informed no they didn't say consent they
didn't say I want to be consented they
said I wanted to be informed and
actually 80% of the participants said
they would want to read the paper if
their tweet was in it I was actually if
my tweet was in a paper I would totally
want to read it and I think that's
probably true like if I wasn't a
researcher people also cared about
things like what the purpose of the
study was whether they would somehow be
identifiable on the data which they
certainly may be if it's for example
qualitative research and so we asked
about a lot of these contextual kinds of
factors and there were some things that
obviously bothered people a lot more us
feel like it's like the darker shades of
blue here obviously people don't want
their tweets collected from a protected
account which mostly is probably not
happening because that arguably does not
constitute public data people are also
very uncomfortable with deleted tweets
being used which is kind of an open
question right now and people are also
more comfortable if the data was it was
a large data set or it was being
analyzed by a computer instead of a
person the sort of idea of obscurity
um for the point of all of this is that
this isn't like this image is not flat
like people weren't just like oh you
know research is fine it doesn't matter
you know how it's being done or who's
doing it or whatever because I think
that these kinds of context matter so
data collection decisions should not
be contacts agnostic it matters what
kind of data you're collecting what
you're gonna do with it who you are what
the expectations and norms of the users
are so the idea that it doesn't matter
like what the tweet is I think is a
little silly this is my first big point
that I would love anyone watching this
to internalize which is that public and
this is not the only context that
matters I can tell you I have read the
methods sections of many many many
papers were the only way that this is
addressed is the data was public and one
of the reasons is this is a problem it's
because and this is a finding from a
paper published by someone else a couple
of years ago and that's 72% of articles
in PubMed which is a health database
that used Twitter data quoted at least
one tweet which led back to the Twitter
user eighty four percent of the time so
this is pretty common right particularly
you doing qualitative analysis is to
include your data in the paper examples
in a codebook or in your findings or
whatever and of course you can take text
and put it into the search of Twitter
find it pretty easily in fact there was
a case a few years ago where a paper was
published and included a codebook and a
journalist who was writing about that
research put those tweets it from a
codebook into Twitter found the tweets
contacted the people who tweeted them
and said hey your tweet was in a
research paper can I talk to you about
it which in that case actually was not
particularly harmful because the paper
was about like language on Twitter like
it wasn't anything you know that could
potentially harm people but imagine if
it was a tweet from PubMed or something
about health for example so the idea
that we would treat treat a tweet that's
like this exactly the same as a tweet
that's like this and and this is off you
skated for the same reason I would
rather not share tweets like this
publicly but it's based on a real tweet
these two things are not
equivalent right and if you're only
ethical metric is is it public that
would suggest that these two things can
be treated the same which means that it
would be fine for example to quote both
of them in a paper or you know we're
seeing a lot of research lately that is
creating classifiers based on tweets I
can tell from your social media whether
you have a certain mental health
condition for example you might
therefore put in a paper a codebook that
basically diagnoses people in your paper
and imagine the potential harm of
finding out that an algorithm thinks you
have a mental health condition for
example this can be particularly
problematic we're talking about
vulnerable communities so my PhD student
Brianna did interviews with people who
are part of online fandom which has a
large percentage of LGBTQ people so she
talked to them about research ethics for
that particular community and one of the
things that we found was that even if
the content is not about something
obviously sensitive simply being in a
space where you have a particular
privacy concerns like for example you're
not out in your real life means that the
potential harm if you're content being
amplified outside the context where you
originally put it it's huge
and people told us stories for example
about how fan artists were really
worried about their work being reposted
by like BuzzFeed or something which
happens because what if someone in their
real life recognizes their art style and
it sends them to their tumblr where
they're out so these are the kinds of
things that matter when you're thinking
when you're collecting this kind of data
not just what the content concert is
about but who created it and the other
thing that matters is what you're going
to do with it
so also if you're collecting content
from a particular community to help
build an algorithm or technology where
the outcome of that technology could
harm that community like a classifier
for whether someone is queer how would
you feel knowing that your content
helped like fuel this technology that
you think can be can be harmful and
another example of where the purpose of
something really mattered it's one of
our favorite ethical scandals Cambridge
analytic ah so most people think about
this as a privacy scandal but it was
also a research ethics scandal because
the original data collection that
connected personality tests to Facebook
Likes was put forth as a research study
for science here give us you know fill
out this personality test and give us
access to your Facebook account for
science and if people had known how that
the model created from that data would
actually be used maybe they wouldn't
have done that right so the idea that it
doesn't matter what you're gonna do you
know with with with the eventual output
of your of your research like doesn't
matter that also seems a little silly to
me and Cambridge analytical also kicked
off a lot of really interesting
discussions one of my favorites was this
news op-ed that was published where the
author suggested that part of the cause
of this kind of scandal in addition to
other similar sorts of things and
comparing it to ethical reckonings in
other fields like collapsed bridges and
you know unethical medical experiments
etc was that software engineers treat
safety and ethics as specialties rather
than the foundations of all design when
I read this I thought yep
yep that is exactly the problem that we
have here and what I think it's
indicative of is this problem which is
the I'm just an engineer problems and
this is a quote from this particular
article it was about someone giving a
talk about a predictive policing system
and someone asked about ethics and
respond to us well I'm just the engineer
you know this is for someone else to
think about the ethical implications
around the same time there's a similar
situation where there was a radio lab
interview the researcher who had created
technology that took in audio and made
very realistic-looking video and the use
case they used as an example was
President Obama because there's so much
audio and so you know the result of this
research is President Obama giving a
talk that he never gave and the
interviewer asked well you know the
obvious use case of this technology is
fake news so how do you feel about that
and the answer was like well I'm sure
they're like really smart people who can
think about the social and ethical
implications of this technology you know
and the way that I like to think about
this is there are people whose job it is
for example on a construction site to
think about safety so safety engineer is
a job but that doesn't mean that the
person putting up the drywall like walks
by a live wire and it's like oh well
that's for the safety engineer to think
about or if they're never shown what a
what live wire looks like right I mean
it is a specialization I guess I am a
specialist in this but that doesn't mean
that it's not also everyone's job to be
thinking about and I would suggest that
part of this problem the I'm just an
engineer problem is caused by the
frequent way that we teach computer
science which is that ethics is a
specialization and
because we often silo it in its own
class as opposed to teaching it as part
of technical practice so that's my my
other big point here is that ethics is
not just a specialization so I've been
doing some work lately in this area
ethics education and computer science in
particular and in a paper that was
published not very long ago sorry for
this really ugly table it's from the
paper we looked at AI machine learning
and data science classes in the top
computer science programs as defined by
US News and World Report
so you are in there somewhere these are
anonymize but I can tell you that you're
one of the better ones this is good go
Stanford so we looked at syllabi and
we're course descriptions for every
class where we could find one and we
coded for whether there was any mention
of anything that could reasonably be
considered ethics like we were very
generous like if if you have half a date
on differential privacy you get a thumbs
up on this right and the vast majority
do not and this includes even like at
standalone ethics classes so out of you
know over a hundred technical classes in
this dataset
less than twenty had any mention of
ethics and this is an area of computer
science that you would think would be
particularly important here right like
we're not looking at like database
classes or Theory classes or whatever
like this is a I machine learning and
this is something that people have been
thinking about for a while in the
mid-90s the NSF funded a task force to
figure out how to do epics and CS
education so a bunch of smart people
came back and said it should be
integrated into every single class
having a standalone class is good too
and you should do both but if you can
only do one you should integrate it and
so in
1995 or 1996 they published this in C
ACM as a recommendation and the Dean of
a computer science department wrote a
letter to the editor that said this is a
terrible idea because this is not
computer science this thing you know
it's hard to imagine computer scientists
teaching it discussing the social and
ethical implications of computing it's
not doing computer science I would like
to think that maybe we're a little more
nuanced now and I would like to think
that particularly in the past few years
as we see sort of an increasing number
of ethical controversies in the news
that our attitudes towards this or
changing
um so I'm doing some work in
introductory programming classes this
semester I'll talk about some more in a
moment
but part of what we did was a pre survey
at the beginning of these classes we
have a mixture of computer science
majors non majors who are taking a
computer science class information
science majors and also students who are
taking a class does not involve
programming to feel like computation
requirements so basically students who
actively don't want a program and we ask
them got a lot of things one of the what
are the things that we ask and this was
a response how much do you agree with
the statement that was drawn from the
quote that I just told you discussing
the social and ethical impacts of
technology as part of doing computer
science the pink here is various shades
of agreement and so we saw more
agreement for the statement from non
computer science majors and then
relatedly in my job after graduation I
will have a responsibility to think
about ethics also saw higher agreement
for this from non majors and this is not
like computer science majors versus
philosophy majors the biggest major in
the non majors is actually advertising
so I'm actually kind of glad that
advertising students think they're going
to
think about ethics that's good so I
think that one way to solve this problem
is to integrate ethics throughout the
entire computer science curriculum for a
few reasons one is that it emphasizes it
as part of technical practice and not an
add-on or a specialization
I think this is important because when
you learn you know when you take a
machine learning class you should learn
that like thinking about the bias and
your training data is part of doing it
if you don't do it you're bad at it
similarly when you take an intra
programming class and you write your
first line of code you should be
thinking about the power that that gives
you and the consequences of any kind of
technology that is created I mean even
something like a database class the fact
that the way that you categorize things
is something that has inherent power
right there's always something that's
relevant to the impact that any kind of
technology that you're going to build is
going to have on society integrating
also avoids isolating ethics from its
context so that we can think about how
this actually fits into technical
practice and it ensures that everyone
who takes the technical class is exposed
to ethics content because not everyone
who takes an intro programming class is
going to go on to take more right or if
you learn to code in middle school you
might not do more and you can do a lot
of damage for the little bit of code
right like you think about the potential
bad actors from Cambridge analytic huh
like whose psychologist self taught data
scientists the whistleblower you know
sometimes required ethics classes or
taught at the very end of your CS degree
and Mark Zuckerberg dropped out so so I
think that these things are really
important reasons why we should be
integrating it throughout and I have
some suggestions for ways for ways to do
this one is
how do I make students care how do I
make them think it's relevant like I
actually find it unlikely that you can
like exist in the news system today and
not like think that ethics is something
that's impacting technology right now
right I don't I don't actually think
it's as hard to make this argument as it
would have been five or ten years ago
another thing that is gaining some
traction is creating modules that can be
put into different classes in
conjunction with experts like ethicists
this is something that's happening at
Harvard they're embedding philosophy
grad students and postdocs into every
computer science class to work with
instructors and you can include ethical
components as part of assignments you
know what are the what are the ethical
implications of this thing that you're
building or this thing that you're
designing and also recontextualizing
existing assignments to include implicit
ethical considerations and also to start
at the very beginning so actually it's
these last two things that I'm working
on right now so I am helping to embed
ethics into introductory programming
classes at CU and one of my priorities
was making this as little work on the
instructors as possible particularly for
the computer science classes where
there's like a thousand students in a
semester so what I did was I took the
assignments that they were already doing
here's the assignment that you know
teaches conditionals and here's the one
that does iteration and thinking about
how to change the assignments so that
they would inherently bring up some kind
of ethical issue so we've been working
on that myself and some some PhD
students in my lab and these are just
little chunks of two example assignments
one so the assignment that was already
in a computer science class to teach
conditionals was having them create a
fortune-teller like how long is your
lifeline and here's your fortune
so we redid that assignment so that they
the problems were very very similar but
instead it was about serving
personalized ads on a social network
platform and so this I know you're not
gonna have time to read this but this
one at the top here is basically a way
to tee up a conversation about Cambridge
analytic huh
about how the ads that you see might not
just be you know you have a dog so we're
gonna advertise dog food that was the
first problem they did but instead
because you have a dog or because of
these other things we know this thing
about you and therefore the ads that
we're gonna serve to you are intended to
speak to you as the kind of person that
you are yes if we just left it like this
that would be true but all of this
involves conversation our route around
it that that this is not the way that we
should potentially be doing things or I
mean the other thing here is that we're
doing this with non majors as well and
this is a literacy issue like you also
need to understand what's happening and
in fact I've been doing versions of
these problems in the non-coding class
as well and like how do algorithms work
so rehearsing these same kinds of things
it's like a I think you can't critique
technology unless you understand enough
about how it's gonna it's going to work
but you're right you would absolutely
not want to do these things in isolation
without the conversation around it we
have another problem where it's based on
college admissions data which these are
mostly freshmen so is something that's
very fresh on their minds here's some
kinds of things that admissions
algorithms might take into account
build an algorithm that would suggest
students based on this data to be
considered farther and then it's taking
them through problems where they're
finding certain kinds of outliers in
order to think about where these kinds
of algorithms might fail or where they
might provide
unexpected or undesirable results these
are just a couple of examples and we're
working a lot more with this if you are
interested in teaching ethics as part of
the classroom you teach teaching ethics
class one thing that I have available is
a gigantic spreadsheet of tech ethics
syllabi that I had crowd-sourced and a
couple of years ago which you can find
here if you want to look but I but I
have some good news which is that we've
also done some analysis on these syllabi
and have a paper that's coming out soon
in addition to a giant database that we
have created of all of the readings that
are taught in about 115 tech ethics
classes so we've done some very basic
analysis home like the kinds of things
that are being taught when people teach
tech ethics and one of the things that
I'm hoping is that you can see
connections between these topics these
are mostly standalone ethics classes you
can see connections between these kinds
of topics and what could be taught in
for example a technical class another
solution that has been put forth you
know to this computer science ethics you
know the scandals and how we teach and
this sort of thing is that computer
science needs the humanities and that
and I agree with this I think that
having computer science students trained
not only you know in ethical and social
issues and the technical classes that
they're taking but having to engage with
broader curricula around the humanities
etc is really important though I'm also
not really on board with the idea that
like everyone needs to be a computer
scientist I think you know we're seeing
this big push for like stem stem
everyone needs to be stem
which I mean having having more people
to fill these jobs etc is really good
but I also think that it's really
important to have a even a small amount
of computational literacy in order to
understand as I said before understand
technology enough to be able to critique
it or to understand kind of how it's
being used on you so I have been
spinning up more work around broadening
participation in computing partly with
this kind of goal in mind I've also been
working in the non-coding class that I'm
teaching to engage with some more basic
computational literacy for the same
reason and all of this is going to come
back to this in a moment I promise but
to tee up the next part I need to
explain something real quick which is
what fanfiction is who knows what
fanfiction is okay so most of you I this
number has raised in the past like five
years and I've been giving talks about
this issue and so I've had a lot of work
around fanfiction communities and in
particular this platform archive of our
own and if you want to read a lot about
this I have a high paper from from 2016
about what I think is a really
remarkable online platform and one of
the reasons it's because it was built by
the community that uses it so fanfiction
is you know stories about Harry Potter
Captain Kirk there are other kinds of
fan works like art fan vids remix videos
and this is not a new thing this is like
the OG user-generated content I mean
women we're creating remix videos with
VCRs in the 80s and Star Trek episodes
like before anyone had even thought of
YouTube and this often has involved
learning technical skills
and this website was in response to the
migration across different fan platforms
over time and the community feeling that
none of these platforms serve their
needs or even worse like we're actively
working against them didn't want them
there etc and so there was this idea
that oh we should just build our own
thing and today there are over 5 million
works and over 2 million users it's also
there are a lot of really really good
design vision design decisions and
interesting things on the site around
things like inclusivity accessibility
and lots of very interesting things that
come up in part because it was built by
the community that uses it but the thing
that's fascinating about this is the
demographics this particular community
so this is some data from a fan
run census and I'm showing you this
because this was a data set of about
12,000 people I've done surveys that are
more recent to validate this but they're
only like two or three thousand people
but this is about standard and they're
actually in this lake this is mostly our
kind of our own users but consider it
like transformative fandom people who
write fanfiction etc I'm not talking
about like people talking about Star
Wars on Twitter um more people who
identify as female than cisgender men
for example in this particular community
and also a really a large percentage of
people who identify as LGBTQ and though
I don't have data about this a large
number of people with disabilities
anecdotally in fandom and these are the
people who not only built this archive
but also have engaged and a lot of other
kinds of computational projects that
were really successful
as I mentioned the design of our cave of
our own is remarkable in a number of
ways one is that the search tagging
organization system is something that
anyone who's building any kind of
informational organization system should
really should really learn from also
they just want a Hugo Award for it which
is for science fiction which is and this
is a story that I wrote when they were
nominated and I was basically like this
is not only a win for like diversity in
science fiction it's a win for diversity
in tech because particularly if you
compare this community to open-source
and this is an open-source project I
mean really remarkable right and the
other thing is that they had a strong
value early on that they only wanted
this to be built by the people who used
it like not bringing in outside
developers so as the person who started
it told me we realized we were gonna
have to grow our own so the other thing
that happened was a lot of people
learned to code so that they could help
develop the archive and this is actually
something that I had seen anecdotally in
fandom for a long time for lots of
different types of technical skills so
the developers that I talked to talked
about how this process of learning
technical skills or to help on the
archive was empowering that the learning
community was positive some of them
specifically would talk about it in
contrast to open-source communities that
they might have tried to slip into and I
also heard this for people who have
learned other kind of technical skills
so for example one person said that they
learned Python so that they could like
create a random romantic pairing
generator her fanfiction characters and
I heard this kind of story over and over
and over I taught myself these technical
skills or I learn these technical skills
in this community of fandom because I
wanted to
do something to contribute to this thing
I loved and with archive of our own the
way that this was often framed was
because I wanted to make a platform that
was better for my community that was
more inclusive and it was safer so this
is one of my more recent projects this
is recently funded by the NSF and it is
led by my PhD student Brianna and what
we're doing is looking at different
examples of these kinds of computational
projects as a particular path towards
broadening participation in computing
not this idea that we're going to like
airdrop diversity into a computer
science major or a tech company but
instead that there might be other
pathways toward computational learning
in communities of people that are
traditionally under underrepresented and
in particular when the impetus for this
is to do something to make their
community better or to increase
representation which actually is a big
thing behind the creation of all
fanworks
and for example if you look on our Kevin
Brown you will see that by far the most
common romantic pairings for example are
not heterosexual and that there are
often stories about bringing more women
into a story where they worked there
actually my first fanfiction when I was
in high school was like giving the
female characters and Star Trek more to
do and this is a pretty common story
right we've also seen similar kinds of
things with disability writing
characters with disabilities into
stories in a way that are not
represented on screen and sometimes this
also involves learning technical skills
so one of the areas that we're
investigating is video game modding so
learning to codes that you can mod video
games to make them more queer or to make
them more accessible and then another
example
is social platforms for fandom so you
may have heard about tumblers adult
content ban back in December and there
was a lot of worry about this I'm
particularly the kind of content that is
often central to fandom um and in the
work that we've done particularly around
looking at how people move across fandom
platforms over time
because some people like started off on
Usenet and now they're on tumblr and
tumblr is not super popular right now
actually and not even because of this so
I you know going back to the to their
research how they excel people being
concerned about researchers and
journalists etc finding fandom data and
amplifying it so the issue with tumblr
is that you can either be all public or
all private so there there are two
problems that are caused by a tumblr for
this particular community one is the
privacy issue so if you are concerned
about being outed for example there's no
way to like have your content be private
just the people who want to see it
except for limiting the discoverability
of it which is a problem if this is an
important support space right so as I
said a lot of people talk to us about oh
I didn't even realize that you know
these kinds of communities existed until
I stumbled onto fandom and then suddenly
I was able to talk to people who I never
could have found in my real life so if
we start making things completely
private and we also limit the
discoverability which limits the benefit
of those comes to support spaces the
other problem is that tumblr doesn't
allow for sub communities I mentioned
some of my work is around online
governance which often means social
forums and other kinds of rules so it
turns out that if a community is
completely flat like Tumblr or Twitter
but you know what there are different
kinds of people on there who have
different kinds of social norms and when
you throw them all into one
place there's conflict and so there
isn't the ability to create sub
communities and you're gonna see see
more of that so for both of these
reasons there's a group in Finland right
now building a site called pillow fort
which kind of looks like Tumblr and live
journals smooshed together which has the
same kinds of affordances as live
journal that has granular privacy
settings and sub communities so we're
doing some participant observation there
now and are hoping to talk to the people
who are building it as well and so it's
a preview of some work that I'm really
excited about coming up now I promised
in the title of this paper that I was
going to give you three lessons for
ethical texts so in truth in advertising
here in my three lessons so one of them
is that data is people and publicness is
not the only context that matters when
it comes to data I think that this is
something that we should be talking
about in terms of in particular machine
learning ethics in the same way they
were thinking about bias is the
provenance of data and where it comes
from also no one is just an engineer
when I wrote the op-ed that I pointed to
briefly earlier the tagline was if you
work in tech and you don't think about
ethics you were bad at your job if I
could like a wave a magic wand and
change something about the culture of
the tech industry right now that would
be it is that everyone is at least
thinking about this I think that that
could go a long way and then that there
are a lot of benefits to empowering more
people to build and/or critique
technology and that we should be
thinking about this in part by looking
at informal learning spaces where we
might be seeing more positive
experiences with technology learning
than we might see in some other context
so to close I will thank my really
awesome research lab and so these are my
PhD students as well as some undergrads
and scattered law student in there and
thank you
[Music]
and there is time for questions yes well
things we stroll in the day-to-day is
what exactly are we supposed to do right
if we have something that the main news
could be fake news shall we not doing it
wrong
the question comes because if we don't
do it someone else probably bad actor
don't do it anyway so shouldn't we be
doing it at least to to keep control
what we are doing I'd agree with the I'm
along mean from that perspective I'm
fine to say I'm only living here because
if I don't do it I'm sure someone else
will do it
and which and will recognize it so if I
do it at least I have control of what
we're doing we understand it a lot so
the question is what we are supposed to
do it with if we have a technology that
has a potential to be to do bad things
shall we stop doing it and let other one
that won't care a sauce another
government many more burns will do it
rockets were easy so what what was it
the actual other construction do suggest
this happen yeah so see you bring up
this sort of what do we do a problem
which I think is the big one here so I'm
gonna answer the question that you gave
me and then I'm gonna answer another
question that you didn't ask so you know
I gave a couple of examples of things
that put technologies that could have
really really bad unintended
consequences I mean I think the first
step is that there should be some
recognition for the kinds of
consequences right so like a lot of the
examples that I brought up you know when
confronted with the issue it was like
deer in headlights right but if you're
thinking about the potential unintended
consequences from you know the
foundations of the design of that thing
there are potentially ways that you
could mitigate it right so are there way
you know so the fake news technology for
example are there ways that it could be
built that would you know make it more
obvious that it was fake for example
are there ways that you know one thing
that I think about is make is sharing
this technology or sharing data so for
example do you share the data set from
one of the you know facial analysis
algorithms that can like determine
someone's gender or sexual orientation
or whatever I think that there are
solutions that as well for example in
terms of vetting the people who are
using it I don't necessarily know the
answers to all of this off the top of my
head but if you're able to anticipate
what the problems could be there might
be ways to mitigate it or to make the
kinds of negative consequences less
likely
so the related problem that you didn't
ask was well what happens when I'm like
worker B at a tech company and I think
that something bad is happening what am
I supposed to do about it I think this I
think that is also a really big problem
and something that we should be talking
more about because I think that part of
training responsible computer scientists
isn't just like teaching them to be able
to spot ethical issues but then what
kinds of things do you do after that it
means learning how to organize learning
how to speak to power and these I think
are really hard things too so in some
ways I have offered you questions and
not answers but the more people who are
thinking about the questions better yes
[Music]
yeah they might do things like mine
public videos for good and other people
like companies or people who learn to
code the archetype of Mark Zuckerberg or
whatever for bad and relatively few
lines of code so do you Facebook wash
and step in and say you don't really
have a choice here you have to be
ethical
so the problem is that a law the laws
definition of ethical might be
questionable I mean so I I am always a
little wary of jumping to regulation as
a solution in part because law and
ethics are not the same thing and I
would rather people be thinking about
ethics and law so like a really good
example of this is the data scraping in
terms of service right so like my
opinion of data scraping provisions in
terms of service is that we shouldn't be
using them to make decisions in either
direction I can think of circumstances
where you might scrape data and it would
be completely ethical I can also think
of like unethical reasons that that
provision might be in a Terms of Service
and I also think that like not having a
provision like that is absolutely not
carte blanche to do it and so you know I
so I'm a little wary about about jumping
to regulation and I do think that in the
current like in the current way that
things are working which is that right
now ir B's are handling most of what
people consider research ethics I do
think there might be some benefit than
to IR B's being potentially a path to
evaluating this kind of thing just
because I don't know what other
structure is in place right now I mean I
would like I would like to think but
like I can go around and tell everyone
like here are the things that you should
be thinking about and then people would
actually do it but that's just not gonna
be the case right people are also gonna
disagree about what constitutes ethical
so yes and no I guess would be my actual
answer sigh question yes it's it's
historically rearward-facing right
they're still worried about injecting
people with syphilis how do you how do
you think we can get the IRB to to be in
front of these issues and and and be
kind of a contributor to the discussion
like
they seem to be worried about
yesterday's problem well I mean and I
mean so obviously IRB should be very
concerned about injecting people with
syphilis so whoa yes yes but like so one
of the problems that I our B's are set
up to like deal with like that's what
they were built for right so they've
never been particularly good at dealing
with social science and just I'm and I'm
sure many of you were thinking like oh I
are B's like already have too much like
they do tend to get kind of ridiculous
sometimes because they're not about
ethics they're about compliance like I
mean I tell this to my students all the
time because they'll ask me like oh do I
need to put in an IRB amendment for like
this tiny little thing they're like when
it's obviously not an ethical problem
and I'm like I know you're completely
right unfortunately the IRB doesn't care
about ethics they care about compliance
so that's actually the reason why I'm a
little hesitant to say that they should
be the ones to be handling this I have a
collaborator who's done a bunch of
research with IRB Xand like how they
think about this public data thing and
the answer is like it's a mess like some
of them care some of them don't some of
them are like actively scared of it this
is a vastly inconsistent you know to
some extent I think that research
communities might be better positioned
to do this but as you know being on the
sig high ethics committee which like
that's what we do there's so much fear
around creating guidelines because of I
mean ethical pluralism for one thing
like who decides with ethical and I
would say this so I think the number one
thing that we can be doing right now is
to be having many more open
conversations about this because right
now like nobody's talking about it
nobody is writing about it in their
papers and so there's no way for the
community to form norms so if I can like
change one thing right now is to people
start writing about this in the methods
section of their papers because then we
also get good examples that other people
can learn from yes
yeah I think that sometimes IBC justify
where when we have this conversation in
tech it's like a very reactive
conversation of like : we are gonna do
something about like let's try not to do
the bad thing I need you also do a
really beautiful job of pointing to the
fact actually like there folks in
community who are like generating not
just soar like be opting to write look
generating a beautiful version of what
privacy should look like or what are
like data relationships should look like
and I think like there's a lot of people
that have power to do that generative
work but they like leave this walk away
like they don't know right so I'm
curious like I guess the two questions
are one like what are the questions that
we ask ourselves and our communities to
figure out that what is the dream what
is the ideal and lovely privacy data
situation and like what are some of the
answers that you're hearing to that
question now so I'll give you maybe part
of an answer to that so one of the ways
I'm in parsing your question is like
what are some ways that we can better
train people to be able to like think
through these things and like
potentially be able to like think what a
better world could be or what how they
can mitigate negative consequences etc
and so one thing that I think is a skill
that we should be teaching technologists
is how to creatively speculate like how
to think about the future I'm so like
recently there was a suggestion that
people should start writing about the
potential negative consequences of their
research in their papers and one of the
critiques to this suggestion was how am
I supposed to know that right which is
which is fair but I think that like
being able to speculate about the future
is something that we can get better with
with practice so I use a lot of science
fiction in my teaching and also like
writing science fiction and so like I
have this teaching exercise called the
black mirror writers room that
encourages people to like think about
current technology take it a step
farther
think about the cautionary tale and then
also to think about how we don't get to
that future I mean this obviously isn't
going to train us all to be like fortune
tellers but I think it's a good skill to
practice